with the war raging in ukraine there's
been a growing movement within the
united states to boycott one of russia's
best-known products
vodka
vodka is the best-selling spirit in the
united states
however many business owners and bar
patrons have been removing the bottles
of russian-made vodka from shelves
dumping it out and some states have even
banned the sale of it
so far the governors of utah new
hampshire north carolina and west
virginia have issued executive orders
instructing their state's alcohol
control agencies to remove russian
liquor from shelves both ohio and iowa's
governors have ordered their state's
alcohol control agencies to halt
purchases of russian produced liquor
pennsylvania's liquor control board on
sunday instructed state-run fine wine
and good spirits liquor stores to halt
the buying and selling of russian
products following a plea from governor
tom wolf
oregon's liquor and cannabis commission
on monday ordered stores to remove
russian-made liquor from sale storing
remaining supplies of the liquor in a
portland warehouse
and some states who haven't flat-out
banned it have still made their stance
known like texas governor greg abbott
who is asking stores to voluntarily
remove russian products
or senator tom cotton of arkansas who
tweeted that americans should dump
russian vodka and send the empty bottles
to ukraine to use for molotov cocktails
the boycotts and bands are a meaningful
show of solidarity with the people of
ukraine however bands and boycotts won't
impact sales that much as russian vodka
sales have declined 79 over the past 10
years
in fact russian vodka accounted for just
18.5 million dollars or 1.3 percent of
all vodka imports to the united states
in 2021.
compare that to the 660 million dollars
imported from france
291 million dollars from the netherlands
177 million dollars from sweden and 137
million dollars from latvia
russian standard is one of the leading
russian vodka brands in the us
but you can see how its sales are
dwarfed by non-russian brands like
tito's new amsterdam and smirnoff
while smirnoff is another high-profile
vodka brand that traces its origins to
russia it is no longer based in russia
and smirnoff consumed in the u.s is
produced in plainfield illinois so while
the russian vodka ban packs a symbolic
punch it really only impacts a tiny
proportion of total liquor sales
but regardless of sales the message is
clear
[Music]
you